the united states and many other
countries around the world has been
levying sanctions against iran since the
late 70s but even recently what we have
seen is that there's a lot of
conversation around some of those
sanctions there's all kinds of things to
pay attention to whether it's oil
natural gas nuclear arms and many other
aspects that are hyper complex but now
there's a report out that says that iran
has actually set up a clandestine
banking and finance system to circumvent
u.s lead sanctions of course this is
what we should expect if you cut a
country off from the global financial
system they have to figure out a way to
transact and if they can't use the u.s
dollar-based system they're going to do
something else there's been a lot of
talk recently about the idea of using
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies to avoid
sanctions and the truth is that the
system just isn't big enough to actually
accommodate any sort of international
trade for an actual country that's
trying to do it in a material way and so
ultimately now what we're seeing is that
this clandestine financial system that
was set up by iran is having more
details exposed here's how it works the
iranian banks that serve companies that
are barred by u.s sanctions from
exporting or importing engage in
affiliate firms in iran to manage the
sanctioned trade on their behalf those
firms established companies outside of
iran to service proxies for the iranian
traders the proxies trade with foreign
purchasers of iranian oil and other
commodities and sellers of goods for
import into iran they do this in dollars
euros or other foreign currencies
through accounts set up in the foreign
banks some of the revenue is then
smuggled into iran by couriers who
literally carry physical cash that's
been withdrawn from those abroad proxy
companies but much of it still remains
in bank accounts abroad according to the
various western officials now ultimately
we have to ask ourselves are we really
surprised that a country that has been
cut off from the global financial system
has chosen to find some other route to
be able to conduct trade i'm not and so
whether it's trying to actually get the
sanctions lifted as they're doing now in
various negotiations or it's simply
setting up a brand new clandestine
financial system or it's partnering up
with other superpowers around the world
iran was going to do something and so
now that we're getting more details on
this i think the world is waking up to
the idea weaponizing the financial
system weaponizing the us dollar it has
trade-offs and whether we think it's a
good answer or a bad answer for many
problems we just have to be aware of the
totality of the situation hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time